welcome to this special edition of
Hannity I'm Jason japitz in for Sean and
tonight with Thanksgiving in the rear
view mirror the Christmas season is now
in full gear unfortunately between
back-breaking inflation and high gas
prices millions of Americans are
struggling with expenses this holiday
season meanwhile our President Joe Biden
well he's just struggling to get by have
a look at this
I think I think I should answer this one
hello Mr President
foreign
I don't think I can hear you can you
hear me Mr President
[Music]
hello Happy Thanksgiving Mr President
are you there
well we're here
I was so worried this call wasn't going
to go through how are you
President Biden is now 80. the serious
questions about his mental and physical
health are not going away but don't
expect much transparency from the White
House have a look
when will you get your annual physical
Mr President
what do you think I need you just had a
birthday
I've gotten to myself I will get you
part of my physical is already done and
to get it before the end
according to reports Biden is now
weighing whether or not he will run for
a second term but many are wondering if
Biden is even capable of finishing out
this term and now between his low poll
numbers America's economic woes and the
comparisons to Jimmy Carter some
Democrats are ready to move on hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else